Alain lamassour pour évoquer les travaux
de l'observatoire de l'enseignement de
l'histoire en Europe que monsieur le
ministre vous présidez depuis sa
création en 2020 à l'initiative du
gouvernement
français monsieur le Président
l'enseignement de l'histoire en Europe
est un sujet qui vous tient
particulièrement à cœur en tant que
européen convaincu on connaît votre
parcours et votre engagement sur
le sur la construction européenne en
tant qu'Européen convaincu vous à
souligner l'importance de promouvoir une
approche commune de l'enseignement de
cette matière afin dites-vous que les
nouvelles génération ne deviennent et je
vous cite pour moitié nationaliste et
pour moitié amnésique vous rappeliez
dans le monde en 2022 que l'enseignement
de l'histoire est un champ de mine une
cause d'embarras pour tous les pays car
aucun d'entre nous ne supporte qu'une
institution extérieure le Conseil le
blâme ou le classe sur la qualité de son
enseignement en la matière c'est
l'objectif de l'Observatoire que de
comparer les méthodes et les programmes
en vigueur dans les États européens et
d'établir des recommandations afin
d'inviter ceuxci à s'entendre sur un
socle commun d'enseignement à l'occasion
de de cette audition nous sommes bien
entendu impatients d'en savoir plus sur
la méthode de travail de l'Observatoire
et la nature des relations qu'il
entretient avec les différents pays
membres et les différentes autorités
politiques
nous sommes également curieux de vous
entendre pour nous présenter les
principales conclusions de votre rapport
sur l'état de l'enseignement de
l'histoire en Europe que vous avez
publié à la fin de l'année dernière
avez-vous à cet égard noté une
spécificité de l'enseignement de
l'histoire en France monsieur le
Président je vous laisse la parole pour
un propos introductif d'une d'une
dizaine de minutes et ensuite comme nous
avons la coutume de le faire dans cette
commission je donnerai la parole à mes
collègues je ne doute pas qu'ils auront
des des questions à vous poser et afin
de nourrir l'échange et le débat avec
vous avant de vous céder la parole je me
permets enfin de vous rappeler que cette
audition est captée et diffusée en
direct sur le sititees internet du Sénat
et que cette fois-ci ça marche donc nous
sommes bien sur le site du Sénat
monsieur le Président je vous lae la
parole merci monsieur le Président j'ai
vu d'ailleurs que les réseaux sociaux
annoncai déjà notre ce matin merci
monsieur le Président je voudrais vous
vous remercier de votre invitation vous
féliciter de votre
réélection et vous dire combien je suis
impressionné Amu de retrouver des
visages connus et et aimés et puis un
peu impressionné d'être devant la Haute
Assemblée dans votre
commission dans une vie politique assez
remplie j'ai exercer tous les mandats
électifs possibles sauf celui de
sénateur dont je me suis senti pas digne
euh alors j'ai arrêté toute activité
politique depuis que je me suis plus
représenté au Parlement européen il y a
maintenant 5 ans mais j'ai voulu
continuer à essayer d'être utile à la
cause de l'Europe à la cause de la paix
naturellement au rayonnement de notre
pays et je j'ai été amené à m'intéresser
à l'enseignement d'histoire à la suite
d'une série de d'incidents en quelque
sorte ou qui m'ont beaucoup marqué et
j'en citerai un
seul ça remonte à la fin des années
90 Hongrie qui n'était plus communiste
qui était candidate à entré dans l'Union
européenne qui était dirigé à l'époque
derre par un gouvernement socialiste et
où j'étais allé inaugurer des classes
européennes c'est-à-dire financé par
l'Union européenne en vue de diversifier
le le conten et les méthodes de
l'enseignement là-bas et donc je visite
un lycée pendant les cours on pousse la
porteune salle de classe c'était une
classe de seconde un cours d'histoire
et on me montre le manuel alors
évidemment je je ne connais pas le
Hongrois par contre je connais ma
géographie politique et quelle n'est pas
ma surprise de voir sur la page de garde
du manuel il y a la carte de la Hongrie
non pas la carte de la Hongrie
d'aujourd'hui la carte de la Hongrie du
système desac de 1867 c'est-à-dire du
temps de ce que nous appelions l'Empire
austro-hongrois à l'époque le territoire
du Royaume de Hongrie était trois fois
plus grand que celui de la Hongrie
actuelle et il comprenait notamment
toute la
Croatie la
province serbe de
vovaudine le banade de Timy chouarat
etesvar et la Transylvanie qui sont
roumaines pratiquement toute la moitié
sud de
la de la Slovaquie et même une petite
partie de l'Ukraine qu'on appelle la
ruténie
subcarpatique et donc ça m'a fait un
choc parce que c'est exactement comme si
sur la page de garde du des manuels
d'histoire en France ont projeté la
carte de la grande nation napoléonienne
de
1811 qui comptait 130 départements et
qui allait depuis le nord Hambourg
chef-lieu des bouches de l'Elbe jusqu'au
sud Rome chef-lieu des bouche du Tibre
et au milieu les départements de Genève
et de bal en Suisse évidemment ça ne
serait pas très bien ressenti par les
voisins de notre pays et donc à partir
de là euh
je me suis intéressé à l'enseignement
d'histoire à l'école et je me suis
demandé si au moins dans certains pays
pas dans le nôtre
euh le problème est différent me
semble-t-il
l'émergence que l'on constate hélas
presque partout deux partis qualifiés de
populistes
xénophobes et de plus en plus
nationaliste n'avait pas parmi d'autres
causes la mauvaise qualité de
l'enseignement de l'histoire à l'école
et donc à partir de là j'ai voulu y
travailler le l'Union
européenne n'est pas compétente sur
l'éducation son programme pH erasmous
vise à faciliter les
déplacements des étudiants des élèves et
des enseignants mais il n'y a aucune
compétence de l'Union sur le contenu et
les méthodes des enseignement par contre
le Conseil de l'Europe qui est une
institution plus ancienne qui est une
institution très différente qui n'a pas
le pouvoir de légiférer de réglementer
mais le pouvoir de faire des
recommandations notamment pour
transmettre diffuser transmettre les
valeurs communes
européennes a elle compétenence et
donc j'ai convaincu le le gouvernement
et le président de la République de
proposer la création auprès du Conseil
de l'Europe d'un observatoire de
l'enseignement de l'histoire à
l'école au niveau enseignement primaire
et enseignement secondaire
idéalement dans tous les pays de membres
du Conseil de l'Europe donc c'est la
grande Europe c'est 48 pays et en tout
cas au moins dans ceux des pays qui
accepai de jouer le
jeu un
observatoire proposition modeste il
s'agit
d'observer proposition modeste qui est
la seule ble
d'être accepté par les États y compris
le nôtre vous l'évoquez dans votre
propos introductif monsieur le
Président
et
mais le
l'idée que nous avions en tête c'est que
à partir
de la collecte des informations
permettant de faire la
description de ce qu'est l'enseignement
de l'histoire dans les écoles de maximum
de pays européens on pourrait faire des
comparaisons et à partir de là là où on
constate
que les méthodes et les résultats le
contenu de l'enseignement ne sont pas
conformes aux recommandations adoptées à
l'unanimité par le Conseil de l'Europe
ou par d'autres institutions
internationales comme l'UNESCO ou l'OCDE
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une pression
de la base une pression des premiers
intéressés les enseignants les étudiants
les les association de de professeurs ou
ou d'élèves et bien entendu les
parlementaires les médias et cetera
pour améliorer la situation là où elle
doit l'être donc le le Paris c'est que
si la situation n'est pas satisfaisante
aujourd'hui c'est parce que tout le
monde le pressent mais tout le monde
l'ignore en rité et donc si on met au
jour un certain nombre de faits
incontestables à ce moment-là cela facil
a le débat et permettra d'améliorer les
choses donc nous avons créé un petit
organe auprès du Conseil de l'Europe
adossé au Conseil de l'Europe
mais politiquement indépendant c'est
très important donc juridiquement
indépendant et financièrement
indépendant les activités de
l'Observatoire ne sont pas financés par
le Conseil de l'Europe mais par des
contributions des États qui ont accepté
de jouer le jeu c'est-à-dire d'en faire
partie et donc de mettre à la
disposition de l'Observatoire toutes les
informations permettant de décrire leur
système
d'enseignement nous avons réussi à
obtenir l'unanimité des 48 pays sur le
principe de la construction de cet
observatoire et sur ses statuts à
l'issue d'une négociation que nous avons
mené c'était en 2020 entièrement sur
zoom avec 48 pays ce qui était pas
évident mais malheureusement la pandémie
qui a ruiné les finances publiques dans
T nos pays et qui a conduit à faire des
économies ou à refuser despenses
nouvelles a fait que nous nous sommes
retrouvés avec seulement 17
pays alors que nous espérions au départ
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui a mené cette négociation
pour la France qui était Jean-Michel
Blanquer en avoir disons de de douzaines
je reviendrai s'il y a des questions sur
la composition de le le l'Observatoire
et sur le les États-membres mais enfin à
17 pays ça permet quand même d'avoir un
échantillon assez intéressant et nous
avons veillé à mettre en place un
Conseil Scientifique alors il y a comme
dans toute organisation de ce genre en
conseil politique où chaque gouvernement
pays membre nomme en représentant j'ai
été nommé représentant par la France et
à partir de là comme j'étais à l'origine
du projet que j'avais mené les
négociation élu président du comité
directeur politique et le comité
directeur politique a choisi un conseil
scientifique et je suis heureux que nous
ayons à l'unanimité
euh choisi des personnalités
exclusivement sur
leur référence professionnelle puisque
sur les 11 membres du conseil
scientifique il y en a même trois qui
sont originaires et qui travaillent dans
des pays qui ne sont pas des pays
membres de l'Observatoire nous avons
même une australienne
et nous avons
travaillé alors
sous le conseil scientifique qui a
travaillé de la méthode avec la méthode
suivante en envoyant des questionnaires
détaillés aux administration d'éducation
des
États-membres sur permettant d'avoir une
photographie système d'enseignement
depuis qui c'est qui est en charge de
définir les programmes quel est
évidemment le contenu des programmes
comment son chisi et former les
professeurs euh comment quel est le
statut des manuels est-ce qu'il y a
liberté de Manuel liberté de choix quel
est la marge de manœuvre des des
enseignants y a-t-il des problèmes que
les enseignants rencontrent en salle de
classe alors là nous avons envoyé un
second questionnaire directement aux
enseignants euh et nous avons eu
plusieurs dizaines de milli de réponses
donc statistiquement ces réponses ont
une valeur scientifique et nous avons
euh ensuite collectter quand je dis nous
c'est le conseil scientifique c'est pas
le comité politique que je préside j'ai
j'ai beaucoup veillé nous avons veillé à
la
neutralité politique parfaite de
l'exercice et à sa qualité scientifique
et sous l'autorité donc du conseil
scientifique la synthèse a été faite
euh sur la base des réponses de ces
questionnaires nous avons publié notre
premier rapport sur la situation dans
les 17 pays parallèlement
nous nous sommes intéressés aussi mais
là nous n'avons pas publié mais je vais
pouvoir en faire état devant vous à ce
qui se passe dans les pays qui ne sont
pas
membres où nous avons beaucoup
d'informations parce que
euh rien rien n'est confidentiel sur le
contenu des programmes qui est qu'on
peut lire au Journal officiel et sur le
statut des des manuels façon les manuels
on peut s procurer en librairie donc et
il y a des organismes comme l'Institut
Georg
ert à brunsvic en en Allemagne en bassx
qui collationne depuis la la dernière
guerre tous les manuels de tous les pays
européens et sur Internet tous les tous
les programmes donc on on peut savoir
aussi alors y compris avec les archives
du Conseil de l'Europe ce qui se passe
dans les dans les autres dans les autres
pays et donc je vais évoquer devant vous
les principaux enseignements de notre
rapport mais aussi au-delà si vous le
permettez monsieur le Président
euh la manière dont nous pouvons
percevoir aujourd'hui la situation sur
l'ensemble du continent européen euh
nous sommes nous avons eu d'abord des
euh nous avons retiré de cela un certain
nombre d'enseignements qui peuvent être
intéressants du point de vue technique
pour les ministères d'éducation sur les
méthodes pédagogique et notamment sur
l'existence de euh
euh de problèmes communs en fait qui ne
sont pas réglés et qui handicapent
l'enseignement de l'histoire c'est
notamment le problème de la formation
initiale des professeurs sur les l'usage
des nouvelles technologies enfin qui
sont de moins en moins nouvelles
d'ailleurs de l'information enfin qui se
renouvelle sans arrêt maintenant avec
notamment l'intelligence
artificielle et et et là c'est un
problème énorme parce que la sur
l'enseignement d'histoire comme dans
toutes les autres disciplines
l'irruption des d'Internet de Wikipédia
et cetera constiue une véritable
révolution à laquelle les professeurs ne
sont pas bien préparé euh même chose
pour la formation continue des
professeurs parce qu'un autre élément
très
intéressant de l'histoire c'est les
progrès de l'histoire scientifique avec
l'ouverture des des archives notamment
tous les archives la deè Guer guerre
mondiale avec aussi la multiplication
des universités des travaux
universitaires euh autre point commun
extrêmement intéressant
euh la difficulté qu'on rencontre dans
presque tous les pays pour évoquer
certains sujets devant certains publics
alors évidemment nous en France nous
avons tout de suite à l'esprit la
tragédie de Samuel pati et celle qui est
plus récente d'un professeur de
littérature et et n nous savons et nous
avons document
les difficultés qu'on rencontre
vis-à-vis de certains publics
notamment des enfants d'origine ou de
confession musulmane mais mais ça n'est
pas spécifique à la France ça n'est pas
spécifique au public
musulman et ben on a rencontré le cas
d'un pays d'Europe de
l'Ouest où on ne peut pas enseigner l'
choix devant des classe de petits
chrétiens euh parce que il y a des
réactions violentes soit pour nier la
choix soit pour s'en
réjouiron
euh dans d'autres pays notamment des
pays d'Europe centrale et orientale
c'est un problème que la France ne
connaît pas ou dit ne pas connaître
euh le l'histoire des minorités des
communautés minoritaires non religieuses
mais ethniqu euh enfin si elles sont
parfois religieuses comme en Bosnie mais
euh
régionales et cetera donc c'est un point
qui est important à savoir un dernier
problème commun et là c'est pour moi un
grand sujet de surprise dans tous nos
pays on déplore la mauvaise qualité de
l'enseignement de l'histoire et il y a
des réformes tous les ans ou tous les 2
ans dans aucun de nos pays on ne mesure
le niveau des connaissances historiquees
à la fin de l'enseignement secondaire
alors
certes l'histoire est une matière du
baccalauréat mais on ne publie pas on ne
on ne collationne pas on ne tire pas
d'enseignement du résultat des des notes
en histoire au niveau du du baccalau
pour ça je dirais ce sont
des des des enseignements un peu plus
technique que que
politique mais audelà de tout ça il y a
un enseignement politique et nous sommes
ici l'Assemblée parlementaire éminente
c'est ça qui nous intéresse le
plus qui est les difficultés communes
ou spécifiqu à certains
pays la première difficulté qui nous est
commune et je vais peut-être vous
surprendre c'est que nous vivons dans un
âge qu'en Europe notamment parmi les
pays membres de l'Union européenne nous
vivons à juste titre comme l'âge de la
paix
or l'histoire en tant que discipline a
enseigné à
l'école est né partout au 19e siècle en
même temps que les
nations et toutes nos nations sans
exception sont nées dans la guerre par
la guerre et pour la guerre et quand
elles se sont transformé en état ou que
l'aspiration pour devenir des état
commencé à se manifester fortement on a
enseigné l' aux enfants qui était une
histoire nationaliste hein Michelet
relut aujourd'hui la prose du point de
vue de la littérature c'est magnifique
sur le contenu ça fait sourire et un
allemand en Allemagne ran son homologue
écrivait les choses identiques mais
c'est la même chose dans tous nos pays
donc enseigner l'histoire c'était facile
il y avait nous et eux voilà eux c'était
les autres donc les ennemis et on
enseignait à nos
garç accessoirement aux filles ben les
exploits héroïques de leurs
ancêtres de manière à ce qu'ils soient
prêt eux aussi aller mourir le moment
venu pour la patrie et ça ça a été
jusqu'en 1939 dans tous nos
pays or aujourd'hui ben nous concevons
les choses de manière assez
différente en Europe notamment en Europe
de l'Ouest notamment au sein de l'Union
européenne c'estàdire qu' y a plus nous
et eux il y a nous nous et nous il y a
nous fi d'être citoyens français qui
avons besoin et qui aspirons à connaître
le passé de notre pays c'est notre
identité il y a nous Européens qui
appartenons à une civilisation commune
don nous avons besoin de connaître les
formidables réalisation dans le passé
les pages très sombres aussi je ne
citerai que la colonisation et
naturellement les deux guerres mondial
et l'Holocauste dont nous Européens
sommes les premiers responsables et les
premières
victimes et dont les
valeurs que nous pensions être de
valeurs universelles sont maintenant
contesté par une partie du reste du
monde et les armes à la main par la
Russie de Vladimir
Poutine et puis nous ben nous les ce que
Villon appelit les frères humains
c'est-à-dire tous les tous les les 8
milliards d'humains qui sommes désormais
connectés par Internet les uns avec les
autres qui sommes soumis au même dangers
planétaire d'origine humaine que ça soit
le réchauffement climatique ou le risque
d'apocalypse
nucléaire et qui aspiront évidemment à à
à bénéficier à faire bénéficier le le le
monde entier euh des acquis de la partie
positive des acquis de l'expérience
européenne donc enseigner l'histoire
avec le nous nous
nous sachant que le reste du monde n'a
pas la paix en tête mais considère que
la guerre peut-être la continuation de
la politique par d'autres moyens selon
la fameuse formule de clus Vitz c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus difficile et
concilier la fierté nationale et
l'identité nationale avec la tolérance
de ce qui se passe dans les pays voisins
he la compréhension que les pays voisins
ont beaucoup de de points en commun avec
nous mais ont aussi des différences et
que l'interprétation même de certains
droits fondamentaux n'est pas la même
dans tous les pays même de l'Union
européenne c'est quelque chose qui est
assez difficile à admettre et à plus
forte raison assez difficile à
enseigner et je dirais que face à cette
difficulté il y a deux tentations qu'il
faut
éviter alors là je vais permettre la
coquetterie de citations littérair la
tentation George Orwell l'auteur de
1984 avec cette formule cynique qui
maîtrise le présent maîtrise le passé et
qui maîtrise le passé maîtrise
l'avenir et donc les dictateurs ont tout
à fait compris
que leur pouvoir repose d'abord sur la
réinvention du
passé et là nous avons
malheureusement des pays qui succombent
à cet aspect à cette tentation
c'est-à-dire présenter le passé sous un
éclairage qui est favorable à leur
pouvoir
actuel et nous avons sur l'ensemble du
continent européen des pays qui tendent
à succomber à cette présentation que je
qualifierai
diplomatiquement de chauviniste de
l'histoire chauvinisme pouvant aller
jusqu'au
nationalisme
avec ceci s'observant pas simplement
dans la partie centrale et orientale du
continent européen mais parfois dans
certains région d'Europe de l'Ouest je
pense à des pays qui ont décentralisé la
compétence en matière
d'éducation auprès de régions et dont
les régions sont contrôlées
politiquement dans des conditions
démocratiques par des partis
nationalistes régionaux donc c'est le
cas en Espagne nous connaissons ça avec
Max Brisson en Catalogne et au
Pays-Basque c'est le cas en Belgique
avec la Flandre la première ligne du
programme
d'histoire de de flandr c'est en Flandre
nous enseignons une histoire
nationaliste il y a le mot alors il y a
le mot en flamand je sais pas comment ça
se traduit mais
voilà c'est le cas euh en
Irlande le le le le Scott Scottish
National Pany n'existait quasiment pas
enfin était une curiosité il y a 20 ans
euh ben 20 ans après la mise en place de
la dévolution qui fait que en
Écosse le programme d'enseignement est
décidé à Édimbourg bah tout d'un coup on
voit ce parti devenir le parti dominant
en Écosse
euh et puis il y a l'autre
tentation il y a l'autre
tentation et là je citerai Paul Valée
cette phrase assez curieuse et assez
terrible l'histoire est le poison le
plus
puissant inventé par le cerveau de
l'esprit
humain et donc selon cette
cette crainte en quelque sorte certains
pays allon tirer la conclusion que bah
le passé il valait mieux ne pas en
parler parce c'est trop c'était trop
abominable qu'en outre les Européens
avaient joué avaient une responsabilité
toute particulière pour ne fois pour ne
pas dire unique là on tombe dans
l'idéologie W dans tous les malheurs de
l'humanité et que donc il vaut mieux ne
pas enseigner
le passé pour ne pas faire peser sur les
frelles épaules de nos enfants toutes
les calamités de l'humanité surtout en
Europe et donc on nenseigne pas on
nenseigne pas l'histoire au sens d'une
chronologie au sens d'une série
d'événements qui ont des causes qui se
manifestent d'une
manière particulièrement frappante
lorsqu'il y a des guerres des crises des
révolutions et qui ont des conséquences
or
évidemment si on nenseigne pas
l'histoire l'histoire du 20e siècle
l'histoire des traités de paix d'après
la Première Guerre mondiale et
l'histoire des de la conclusion de la
guerre froide comment comment nos
enfants peuvent-ils comprendre ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine ou ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
que vous allez commémorer tout à l'heure
euh hélas monsieur enfin tant mieux pour
la commémoration mais hélas évidemment
pour la
tragédie entre Israël et et la
Palestine ou les
Palestiniens donc ça voilà si vous
voulez le le la difficulté commune
combiner
enseignement
national l'identité nationale et la
volonté de paix de tolérance d'ouverture
au reste du monde
et puis alors il y a des difficultés
particulières à certains
pays et notamment il faut comprendre que
nous vieille
démocratie solidement raciné ben nous ne
sommes pas dans la même situation que
d'autres pays qui sont des démocraties
plus
récentes moins solides parfois plus
fragiles euh et et de vieilles nations
dont les États sont jeunes et dans la
démocratie est encore plus jeune
c'est-à-dire après la fin de la guerre
froide et pas toujours complètement
stabilisée alors pour citer quelqu cas
la
Pologne mais la Pologne comment
voulez-vous éviter que l'histoire de la
Pologne vue de Pologne soit une
martyrologie à partir du moment où ce
malreays a été au 18e siècle découpé en
trois à trois repris par les empires
voisins au 19e siècle euh soumis à la
dictature russe et en partie pour la
Galicie au pouvoir autoritaire qui était
moins moins pénible à à subir donc de
l'Autriche Hongrie et surtout évidemment
qui a été au au au 20e siècle le champ
de bataille des deux monstres Hitler et
Staline j'ai eu un jour un échange avec
le le remarquable Bronislav gueremek
héros de solidarnochque qui était
franco-polonais qui enseignait à la
Sorbonne grand
historien sur sur l'histoire d'apologne
et il me disait écoute Alain tu es bien
gentil mais quel légitimité as-tu pour
parler histoire de la
Pologne nos deux pays ont commencé la
dernière guerre le prier le même jour le
1er septembre 39 ils l'ont fini le même
jour le 8 mai
1945 entre les deux 6 millions de morts
en Pologne 6 millions de morts 600000
français nous étions alliés 6 millions
de morts 3 millions de Juifs 3 millions
de non
juif bon alors ça ne légitime pas les
dirigeants polonais pour raconter ce
qu'ils veulent sur l'histoire de la
Pologne mais ça nous oblige à comprendre
quand même quand nous parlons à des
Polonais que bon autre exemple la
Slovaquie chaque pays a besoin
d'enseigner son passé et aussi d'en être
fier quelque part même si bien sûr il y
a des pages sombres dans notre euh dans
notre passé la Slovaquie est née pour la
première fois
euh lorsque la tchcoslovaquie s'est
cassée en deux euh à l'initiative de
Monseigneur Tiso qui était un un prélat
euh mais qui s'est voulu le fureur
slovaque et qui pendant la guerre
ensuite a euh s'est lancé dans une
compétition avec Hitler pour savoir quel
est celui qui ferait disparaître le la
plus grande proportion des Juifs de son
territoire
bon sachant qu'après il y a eu à la fin
de la guerre une tentative de de révolte
contre le régime de Monseigneur Tiso qui
a échoué et qu'en fait les nazis ne sont
partis enfin l'occupation nazis n'a été
remplacé que par l'occupation communiste
et que le divorce de la part par tchèque
et de la partie slovaque de la
Tchécoslovaquie n'a pas été décidé par
le peuple mais par les deux premiers
ministres de l'époque qui se sont
entenduon c'est évidemment
extraordinairement difficile un dernier
exemple la Macédoine la Macédoine du
Nord quand ce pays est devenu
indépendant en
1991 tous ses voisins l' contesté ses
voisins Serbes contestai son existence
ses voisins albanais consiste contesta
sa
consistance sa composition ses voisins
grecs contestai son nom problème qu'ils
ont réglé depuis et ses voisins bulgares
contestai et contestent toujours
l'existence même de sa langue en
considérant qu'il y a pas de langue
macédonienne il y a qu'une langue
bulgare circulée il y a rien à voir
voilà et donc j'en arrivé c'est comme ça
que quand on additionne les problèmes
communs à tous pays et que l'on comprend
que certains pays ont
des difficultés plus que
d'autres et ont besoin de
temps on a un panorama qui n'est pas
particulièrement brillant je termine par
les deux pires exemples donc je je
termine je suis quelqu'un de tempérament
naturellement optimiste mais je termine
sur une note très noire plus sur pierre
soulage que sur le bleu de
mais mais mais dans la dans les échanges
j'auraai l'occasion de remonter le moral
si cela était nécessaire mais enfin au
Sénat on sait faire la part des
choses l'horreur absolue deux exemples
la Bosnie
aujourd'hui quand il y a eu la guerre
civile de Bosnie vous vous en souvenez
bah on a été obligé de faire appel aux
Américains pour mettre fin aux exactions
des Serbes euh et l'Union européenne est
intervenue après coup pour reconstruire
tout ce qui avait été détruit notamment
les bâtiments publics notamment les
bâtiments scolaires et nous avons mis
comme condition
élémentaire à au financement de cette
reconstruction que désormais les enfants
des trois communautés qui s'étaient fait
la guerre qui é d'ailleurs des
communautés religieuses c'est pas des
communautés ethniques différents
éthniquement euh c'est c'est les mêmes
les mêmes populations mais pour des
raisons historiques des religions
différentes c'est euh les enfantsoté
seraient scolarisés dans les mêmes
locaux et donc si vous allez aujourd'hui
à sarevau à banaluca vous vérifierez
qu'en
effet tous les enfants sont dans les
mêmes locaux sauf que au rez-de-chaussée
vous avez par exemple les petits
musulmans au premier étage les petits
orthodoxes au deè étage les petits
catholiques et que chacun arrive à
l'école avec dans son cartable un manuel
d'histoire dans lequel on lui apprend
que ses parents auraient été tués par
les par du dessus ou par les parents du
dessous et l'autre exemple qui va
peut-être surprendre davantage et
scandaliser encore plus c'est l'Irlande
du Nord autant en Irlande du Sud
l'enseignement de l'histoire est
remarquable et complètement apaisé
autant en Irlande du
Nord vous allez à Bast ou à London Derry
vous constaterez que non seulement il y
a encore plus de murs et et de de faire
barbelet qu'avant l'accord qui avait mis
fin à cette guerre civile qu'il
appelaient les troubles du du Good
Friday du du vendredi saint
98 mais les petits catholiques vont
toujours aux école catholique les petits
protestants vont toujours à l'école
protestante et ils apprennent que leurs
parents ont été tués par les parents de
l'école voisine ce qui veut dire qu'il y
a en Europe des pays ou des régions dans
aujourd'hui en 2024
où l'enseignement de l'histoire sert à
entretenir à feu doux les haines
nationales qui ne demanderont le moment
venu enfin c'est la crainte qu'à
repartir à feu
vif le rôle que jouit l'enseignement
d'histoire même chez nous en
1939 et donc alors que nous avons
réalisé en Europe de l'Ouest au sein de
l'Union européenne et en partie en
grande partie à mon sens grâce à la
construction européenne cette
paix miraculeuse entre nos pays cette
réconciliation entre nos peuples si et
c'est ce que j'évoqué vous évoquiez dans
votre introduction monsieur le Président
si nous n'y prenons pas garde nous
risquons de voir nous nous succéder une
génération faite de nationalistes
d'amnésique et d'ailleurs au passage
d'ignorant complet de ce qu'a été la
construction européenne je vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président et
sans plus tarder je vais donner la
parole à ceux qui l'ont souhaité en
commençant solidarité basse qu'oblige
par Max Brisson merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Président cher al oui d'abord il y a
des raisons très très basses qui
barnaises pour lesquelles j'ai le
plaisir et je suis parement heureux de
pouvoir interroger le le président du
comité de direction de l'observatoire de
enseignement de l'histoire en
Europe cette cette audition en bureau il
y a quelques une bonne
année c'est Pierre ouias et moi-même qui
l'avions souhaité et je ne le regrette
pas et une longue interview dans une
dans le journal
Sud-Ouest m'a fait réactiver la demande
que pierreulas et moi-même
avion formulé lors d'une réunion de
bureau euh
on vient de de prendre conscience
combien la construction des programmes
d'histoire est complexe et l'ancien
inspecteur général que je suis et qui a
mis la main à la patte dans la fabrique
de certains programmes se rend bien
compte que lorsqu'on confond histoire et
mémoire lorsque les la concurrence des
mémoires
vient télescoper la fabrique des
programmes
d'histoire lorsque les querelles
universitaires viennent qui sont
d'ailleurs très légitimes viennent
interférer la construction des
programmes d'histoire c'est certain des
exercices les plus complexes parce que
cela touche beaucoup aux politiques
alors je voudrais d'abord bien sûr
remercier Alen labassour pour sa
présentation le remercier pour le
premier rapport qui a été produit par
l'ohte qu'il préside quant à sa passion
pour l'Europe je crois qu'elle est elle
est connue par chacune et cha
d'entre
nous moi ce qui me paraît le plus
fondamental dans le rapport c'est que 75
ans après les premières étapes de la
construction
européenne la connaissance de l'histoire
commune de l'histoire en partage et sa
dans les programmes est extrêmement
faible je pense que c'est quand même la
perspective européenne et largement
absente de la plupart des programmes et
c'est peut-être déjà une première
interrogation nos histoires ont été
construites dans des temps les
nationalismes caractérisaient l'Europe
cela étant dit cher
Allin la connaissance de notre histoire
commune est une nécessité les retards
sont
considérables mais je crois aussi que la
connaissance de nos histoires
respectives est aussi une profonde
nécessité et qu'elle ne conduit pas
obligatoirement au dérapage
nationaliste et je pense en particulier
que les hussard noir de la
République lorsqu'il portaiit le roman
national ils étaient très
loin de la de l'état de la connaissance
scientifique de l'époque et encore plus
loin de l'état de la connaissance
scientifique
d'aujourd'hui mais après tout ils ont
porté un idéal républicain que nous
avons aujourd'hui tous en partage et que
donc la il faut trouver le bon équilibre
entre la connaissance de l'histoire de
chaque pays et la connaissance de ce que
nous avons en commun et en partage qui
fait notre appartenance européenne à
côté de notre appartenance ma garde ou
française et je pense que c'est cet
équilibre là qui aujourd'hui le rapport
le montre beaucoup n'est pas au
rendez-vous 75 ans après la création du
Conseil de
moi
je j'ai été marqué dans ce rapport sur
plusieurs points d'abord il y a des des
éléments qui nous sont très communs
alors que l'on pouvait croire qu'il y
avait une spécificité française dans
l'enseignement de l'histoire j'ai pu
croire pendant longtemps que l'objet
politique qui était l'enseignement de
l'histoire était une spécificité
française finalement le rapport démontre
que ce n'est pas le cas que notre notre
histoire porté par Lesar noir de la
République on peut la retrouver sous
d'autres formes dans la plupart des pays
d'Europe on peut aussi d'ailleurs
constater que l'enseignement de
l'histoire qui court après la recherche
historique et c'est sa véritable
difficulté celle de la définition d'une
histoire enseignée que notre pays n'est
plus capable aujourd'hui de fournir
alors qu'il le fut dans le passé donc on
constate bien qu' aujourd'hui que
l'enseignement de l'histoire dans tous
les pays d'Europe est aussi marqué par
des flux de convergence que cette
histoire est en mutation permanente et
que cette mutation permanente on la
retrouve dans tous les pays cette
histoire aujourd'hui est très liée à
l'élargissement des champs de la
connaissance historique de la recherche
historique dans les champs couverts par
l'histoire et par les courants dominant
excusez-moi de le dire aussi par les
lunettes avec lequel on regarde
l'histoire d'aujourd'hui finalement rien
n'a bien changé nos lunettes ont changé
elles sont plus haquistes tu le disais
peut-être en tous les cas elles mettent
une place plus grande sur l'histoire des
minorités ou l'histoire du genre qu'on
pouvait le faire dans le passé mais
c'est n nos lunettes d'aujourd'hui ayons
la modestie de penser que les lunettes
demain seront différentes dans
l'approche de
l'histoire je voudrais donc cher Alen
poser d'abord de trois premières
questions parce que jusqu'àors c'était
quelques
remarques
exceptionnellement et parce que j'ai des
convergences àitaines basque et bénaise
je vais mautoriser à dépasser le temps
que nous avons convenu de nous fixer
entre nous mais je promets rassurez-vous
il est déjà dépassé depuis une minute
j'ai dit
l'essentiel moi je voudrais
savoir cette cette vie comment expliquer
d'abord cette absence de perspective
européenne 75 ans après voilà c'est le
premier point la première question
pourquoi l'Europe n'occupe-elle pas une
meilleure place dans la fabrique des
programme au moins dans les pays
fondateurs dans les pays qui ont déjà an
d'histoire commune et partagé n'est-ce
pas sans être sévère n'est-ce pas la fin
d'une illusion que port les pèes
fondateurs de l'Europe celle d'une
grande histoire commune vectrice d'un
destin commun la deè sujet que je
voudrais noter je vais très vite
président en France aujourd'hui reven un
débat plus
francofanais il y a une attente de la
société
fortement exprimé dans le débat public
pour davantage d'histoire
nationale là les résultats alors tu
disais que il y a aucune évaluation
c'est vrai on peut le regretter mais ENF
les inspections successives montrent
bien quand même aussi qu'il y a un
certain nombre de repères et de commun
qui ét une évidence en matière
d'histoire nationale il y 30 ou 40 ans
qui ne sont plus aujourd'hui et que ça
interroge la nation et c'est bien normal
de savoir fait qu'un nombre de repères
ne sont plus au rendez-vous des
connaissances minimales que pouvit avoir
des collégiant Français il y a 40 ou 50
ans donc comment conjug peut-on
conjuguer le retour attendu à une
histoire plus nationale avec la
perspective européenne qui est
nécessaire et avec une histoire qui
reste universelle le sujet n'est pas
simple et ça sera donc ma dernière
question oui merci Monsieur président
monsieur le ministre monsieur lamassour
nous sommes ravis de de vous accueillir
en tant que président de l'Observatoire
de l'enseignement de l'histoire en
Europe d'autant plus ravi que nous
partageons avec vous le fait que
l'enseignement critique de l'histoire
doit être préservé et promu justement
face à la montée du nationalisme du
révisionnisme et à la diffusion
croissante des contrevérités et des
manipulations historiques que vous avez
vous même mentionné dans votre propos
liminaire mais aussi parce que nous
croyons en la valeur émancipatrice
justement de l'enseignement de de
l'histoire je reprendrai d'ailleurs une
phrase de de Jean jores lors de son
discours la jeunesse lui-même disait
l'histoire enseigne aux hommes la
difficulté des grandes tâches et la
lenteur des accomplissements mais elle
justifie l'invincible espoir et c'est
sous ce prisme là qu'on a lu justement
avec attention votre le rapport général
de le hte sur l'état justement de
l'enseignement de l'histoire en Europe
état des lieux qui est présenté et très
intéressant à ce titre vous y insister
particulièrement sur la prise en compte
des perspectives multiples a-t-on
justement aujourd'hui des donné sur la
diffusion du manuel d'histoire c'est
très concret
franco-allemand depuis sa publication
par Nathan en 2006 et sur son usage en
France et en Allemagne
aujourd'hui par ailleurs est-ce que vot
votre observatoire a aussi vocation à
lancer un travail du même type pour
forger une histoire et une
historiographie de l'Europe qui puisse
être partagé à travers le le continent
pour sensibiliser notre jeunesse au
regard des autres sur ce passé commun et
pour lutter justement contre les
révisionnismes votre travail il montre
aussi que nos enseignants s'inscrivent
dans une pratique justement critique et
réfléchie de l'histoire notamment dans
l'évaluation par des exercices
argumentés comme la dissertation plutôt
que des QCM qui sont pratiqués par par
d'autres pays votre travail est donc
précieux pour défendre l'ambition et les
exigences de nos enseignants face aux
critiques facile qui leur sont parfois
adressés ici ou
ailleurs votre rapport il a aussi nous
trouvons le mérite de rappeler les
difficultés justement auxquelles sont
confrontés nos enseignants la sur charge
des programmes est au centre de leur
préoccupation 68 % des enseignants
français trouvent que le programme
d'histoire n'est pas faisable c'est le
plus fort tau derrière
Enor les conséquences de cette surcharge
c'est le manque de temps pour la
formationue vous l'avez évoqué également
et notamment pour des formations au
méthodes actives d'apprentissage aux
pédagogie collaborative et vous l'avez
dit également à l'usage des nouvelles
technologies et de ressources pédagogiqu
innovante pire les enseignants français
sont ceux qui
considèrent le plus que leur offre de
formation s'est
dégradé en histoire comme dans d'autres
matières la formation des enseignants et
nous le disons assez régulièrement dans
cette commission et le talon d'achile de
l'éducation nationale et doit être une
une
priorité enfin on voit que les manuels
scolaires sont la ressource pédagogique
la plus souvent utilisée par les
enseignants tout particulièrement en
France où les enseignants sont ceux qui
utilisent le moins leurs propre
notes cela doit en tout cas nous alerter
à l'heure où justement la ministre de
l'Éducation nationale suivant les pas de
son prédécesseur s'apprête à publier un
décret qui instaure la labellisation des
manuels
scolaires vous qui êtes soucieux de
lutter contre toute histoire officielle
est-ce que ce projet de label attestant
la conformité des annuel scolaire au
programme d'enseignement et sa qualité
pédagogique et didactique délivré par un
conseil nommé par le ministre vous
inquiète autant qu'il nous
inquiète docteur
pierreouas merci merci Monsieur le merci
monsieur le Président je soigne rien
monsieur le ministreis
désolé merci beaucoup pour pour votre
intervention je pense comme vous je
crois qu'à une époque où on explique que
il n'y a plus de grandes de grandes
idéologie de grandes théories le récit
national on est en est une qui s'affirme
avec beaucoup de force et je rappelle
avec vous que l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par la Russie a
été préparé par une une forme de
révisionisme historique que Poutine a
diragé
personnellement 3 4 ans sign tout à fait
tout à fait tout à fait tout à fait tout
à
fait c'est ça c'est ça euh que ou que
que l'Ukraine en tant que pays mais que
l'identité ukrainienne en tant que
langue en tant que nation n'existe pas
et et tout ça a étit fait 3 4 ans juste
avant l'invasion donc on sent qu'il y a
il y a une réflexion idéologique et et
que le r national en fait en fait partie
alors j'observe aussi nous sommes très
proches proche du du 21 février et de la
pantonisation de de Manouchian je je
travaille beaucoup dans les écoles on
voit bien que par par le biais des
manuels scolaires il y a peu d'élèves
qui ne connaissent pas Manouchian et
laffiche rouge et je suis très surpris
vraiment très surpris de voir le
retentissement de cet événement dans
dans la jeunesse parce que ça parle sans
doute à à à des choses extrêmement
profondes sur Qu'est-ce qu'ê français
euh qu'est-ce que finalement conduire sa
vie jusqu'au sacrifice suprême tout ça
c'est des choses qui questionnent des
jeunes dont on dit qu'ils sont
totalement individualistes et qui
s'attachent surtout à à leur confort
personnel c'est pas ce que je vois c'est
pas ce que je vois et là je pense que
l'histoire joue un rôle tout à fait
exceptionnel ensuite je vais je vais
vous parler en tant que historien de
l'Antiquité et et archéologue je je lis
beaucoup l'Emmanuel scolaire et je suis
affligé de la distance qu'il y a entre
l'actualité de la recherche académique
et ce que l'Emmanuel d'histoire en
retienneent sur l'histoire de de la
Gaule il y a 30 ans de retard
c'est-à-dire que les archéologues ont
changé totalement la vision que nous
avons de la Gaule et et et on attend que
l' manuel d'histoire prennent en compte
ce changement alors on n est pas tout à
fait à nos ancêtres les Gaulois qui
vivaient avec des sangliers dans des
hutes mais c'est c'est quand même pas
très loin c'est quand même pas très loin
et et là il y a il y a une espèce de
lapsus don dont je ne m'explique pas la
perputuation on n'y arrive pas moi j'ai
essayé he et et on y arrive pas et pour
et pour reprendre le le propos de Max
Brisson avec lequel je suis tout à fait
en accord sur l'histoire de l'Antiquité
on on voit que la religion devient
quasiment la clé essentielle de compré
enstion et que pour l'Antiquité il
s'agit presque d'une d'une histoire de
la religion de la naissance du
christianisme et cetera et tous les
problèmes économiques qui éta jadiste
relativement fondamentaux ne sont plus
ne sont plus expliqués avec des
appriaries religieux qui peuvent être
extrêmement difficil à comprendre pour
les enfants je prends juste un exemple
dans dans tous les manuels scolaire que
que j'ai lu manuel de de 3e on dit
jamais que le Christ est juif Paul oui
bien sûr parce que sinon on comprend pas
le chemin de Damas mais le Christ non et
sur et sur l'apport de la culture juive
à à ce qu' à ce qu'a été l'identité
française même chose même chose
c'est-à-dire que la culture juive est
vue entre deux choses absolument
terribles la Choa d'une part et et
deuxièmement le christianisme et entre
les deux on oublie complètement que la
culture juive constitutif de la culture
française parce qu'il y a eu des très
grands penseurs de de la
Torah à l'époque médiévale et tout ça
est passé et tout ça est passé sous
silence donc ce que ce que tout ça
m'interroge sur la façon dont don dont
l'histoire est récupérée et de façon de
façon plus large puisque vous vous avez
parlé de l'Europe je je pense que ce qui
serait tout à fait important et qui ser
vraiment une avancée fondamentale c'est
que on puisse
s'entendre sur une liberté académique
quiit qui protègerait partout en Europe
les liberté pédagogique des enseignants
d'enseignant d'enseigner comme ils le
souhaitent je moi je suis partisan d'une
citoyenneté européenne qui garantirait
des droits et la liberté académique
pourrait être l'un de ces droits je
pense que c'est important aujourd'hui
d'apporter aux historiens polonais et
autres une un droit qu'il n'ont pas
merci monsieur le Président allez bon
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour vos propos et
vos explications sur ce rapport de
l'ohte dont vous nous avez fait part euh
peut-être partir du constat par rapport
au niveau des élèves français en
histoire en gros selon un sondage récent
35 % des jeunes ne datent pas le début
de la Révolution française et 18 % des
18 24 ans n'ont jamais entendu parler de
la Choa je pense que cette situation en
terme de culture historique all
multifactoriel on constate également que
le gouvernement a drastiquement diminué
le nombre d'heures d'enseignement
histoire géographie et notamment dans
les lycées professionnels ça a été
divisé par deux donc moi ce qui me
m'interpelle dans dans votre rapport
c'est que on a assez peu on s s'est
assez peu renseigné par rapport à
l'outil numérique je pense que l'outil
numérique participe amplement au déficit
de culture historique et euh
géographique et peut-être qu'on n' pas
mesuré l'impact qu'avait l'outil
numérique sur les générations actuelles
alors si on regarde les différents
moyens d'action et euh puisque c'est
forcément que ce niveau en histoire euh
qui diminue c'est multifactoriel on peut
se dire qu'il y a trois principaux à la
lecture de vos de vos travaux trois
principaux outils c'est à la fois le
contenu les manuels et les programmes
donc ma question c'est comment élaborer
des manuels et des programmes qui soient
totalement indépendant de vision
politique ou de vision parti prix la
deuxième chose c'est la méthodologie on
a bien vu que la méthodologie sur
l'enseignement de l'histoire avait
évolué c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment on a
voulu que ce soit un enseignement
chronologique qu'il y ait une
transversalité que l'histoire soit
enseignée dans plusieurs matières et
puis de faire de lien systématique entre
les matières et sur la formation vous le
dites un certain nombre de d'enseignants
qui enseignent l'histoire finalement ont
un degré de formation très très très
différent donc comment sur ces trois
leviers contenu méthodologie formation
réussir à inverser la tendance de la
diminution de la culture d'histoire en
France je vous merci Mathilde
Olivier merci merci monsieur le
Président merci pour ces pour ces pour
cette présentation moi je revenir aussi
sur sur sur le sur le volet numérique
euh vous avez parlé de de des ressources
numériques et des défis aujourd'hui dans
l'enseignement de
l'histoire à l'heure des réseaux sociaux
il y a toute la question aussi de
comment le numérique les fake news
impactent nos sociétés dans
l'enseignement de l'histoire mais aussi
dans dans la perception de l'histoire
par les jeunes génération il y a
beaucoup de de de professeurs d'histoire
autoproclamé sur sur les réseaux sociaux
qui
qui qui propose une histoire parallèle
et donc comment dans l'éducation des des
enfants des élèves aujourd'hui on leur
donne les clés pour avoir une analyse
critique de la manière de penser enfin
de la manière de d'analyser notre
histoire pour avoir ensuite les clés
d'analyse lorsqu'il se retrouveent face
à ces à ses vidéos à ses fake news sur
les sur les réseaux sociaux et ça fait
d'ailleurs le lien avec a que ce que
disait mon collègue sur euh sur la
Russie et l'Ukraine et et ce et ce et
tout ce ce discours parce que c'est un
enjeu majeur euh aussi de de la
construction des idéologies aujourd'hui
en Europe euh que de ce rapport à
l'histoire donc euh donc voilà après une
petite question vous vous sur sur
l'observatoire en lui-même euh vous
disiez que vous aviez un objectif de de
de d'avoir un petit peu plus
d'états-membres que ce que vous avez
aujourd'hui euh est-ce que vous pouvez
revenir sur les raisons etis les leviers
que vous voyez aujourd'hui pour faire
adhérer plus de de de
pays à cet observatoire je note que des
certains grands pays de de l'Union ne
l'ont pas rejoint
l'Allemagne notamment l'Italie il me
semble non plus bon voilà est-ce que
vous pouvez nous donner quelques
éléments là-dessus et je m'arrête là
avant de vous donner la parole moi je
vais rajouter une question aussi et vous
n avez parlé de l'enseignement AUAU
scolaire est-ce qu'au niveau
universitaire il y a des travaux de
recherche qui là aussi dépassent les les
les pays est-ce que la recherche
universitaire est
très limitée à chaque fois
géographiquement au niveau des des des
pays où est-ce qu'il y a des programmes
communs de recherche est-ce que la
recherche est aussi un lieu de de
confrontation et de
partage ah pardon Béatrice clin aussi
merci alors ça va va être une toute
petite intervention parce que je fais un
constat moi dans l'enseignement primaire
où on demande de voir l'enseignement de
façon diversifiée sous différents anles
sociét sociétau économique et cetera et
on constate enfin c'est un constat c'est
pas que finalement les enfants n'ont
plus aucune idée de la chronologie des
faits historiques et et c'est un réel
problème que qui que on enseigne ça
depuis une quinzaine d'années maintenant
et et franchement c'était désastreux sur
la réalité sur les connaissances
historiques de nos
enfants c'est à quelle heure l' mar
oui très rapidement merci président pour
votre présentation avec énormément de
nuances moi c'est ça qui m'a c'est cellà
qui m'a beaucoup beaucoup parlé lorsqu
l'on a pris connaissance de votre
rapport et des discussions qu'on a pu
avoir avec notre collègue je suis pas
Bernet je ne suis pas des Pyrénées non
plus mais je considère que à l'échelle
de notre pays nous avons un passé en
commun vous l'avez évoqué dans cette
très belle formule le passé ce futur ce
présent cette capacité à comprendre
notre passé pour se projeter dans le
futur
moi ce que je constate dans vos propos
c'est ce soutien que vous apportez
peut-être que à aux enseignants dans
leur enseignement de l'histoire qui
aujourd'hui à mon sens ne sont pas assez
soutenus de ce point de vue-là moi-ême
j'ai des enfants qui sont assez jeunes
ils sont en primaire et au collège et
moi je j'applaudis dès demain le travail
qui est fait par le corps enseignant on
en discuter avec ma collègue euh
effectivement sur cette compréhension de
l'histoire euh dans la mesure où ces
enseignants sont dans les difficultés
qu'on connaît par rapport à l'éducation
nationale mais on a cœur de faire
connaître l'histoire de notre pays mais
moi je le sens plus particulièrement
quand j'échange avec avec le personnel
enseignant dans le cadre de mes
relations parents professeurs cette
volonté aussi d'ouvrir une réflexion non
seulement concentrée sur l'histoire de
notre pays mais sur son environnement
cette évolution aussi dans un monde
globalisé ou comme vous l'avez évoqué
Président on peut plus seulement se
concentrer sur un récit national
articuler autour d'une vision d'un
enseignement construit au 19e et au
début du 2e siècle pardon max nexiste
plusire tout à fait mais
je laissez poser la question me permet
cher max d'exprimer ma vision du sujet
ça fait 40 ans mais on le retrouve
parfois et de s'ouvrir aussi sur des
orientation internationale et de
réfléchir par rapport à ce que vous
évoquez sur l'Union européenne sur
l'Europe cette histoire de l'Europe pour
ne pas construire les conflits de demain
mes questions moi elle posaient plus
particulièrement et euh je me permets de
revenir sur cette construction en tout
cas moi ça a été autour de mon éducation
la question du roman national dans mes
études et cetera quelque chose qui était
extrêmement important euh moi ma
question elle porte sur l'enseignement
de l'histoire qui a une approche plus
rigoureuse elle se pratique comment
aujourd'hui de votre point de vue à
l'université et quelles sont les
approches en Europe qui sont j'ai pas
envie de dire on va distribuer les bons
points mais les bons élèves ceux qui de
votre point de vue se penchent sur cette
question et essaie de d'élargir un petit
peu le cadre de la réflexion ce travail
peut-être historiographique entre pays
et voilà je reviens sur le travail des
professeurs d'histoire géographie est-ce
que nous avons les moyens aujourd'hui
vous avez parlé dans votre rapport de
l'éducation morale et suivique est-ce
que nous avons les moyens nous donnons
les moyens aujourd'hui à nos enseignants
d'élargir par rapport à des des volumes
horaires d'élargir et de renforcer le
enseignement de l'histoire géographie à
destination de nos enfants je vous
remercie j'ai envie de parler de r
nationale je parle de r national c'est
ce que je
veux on l' pas
le
Rapp on est sérieux président moi
j'étais
député on ne va pas autant au fond des
sujets
voilà j'en suis parfaitement conscient
et d'autant que ce rapport pour
l'instant n'est disponible qu'en langue
anglaise exactement mais d'ici un mois
il devrait normalement est disponible
c'est un problème en en papier sur
support papier et et sur support
enfin et et en langue et en langue
anglaise euh alors je je je vais pas
répondre à chacun individuellement parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de questions qui se
recoupe mais je je vais essayer quand
même de de répondre à l'ensemble des des
préoccupations en commençant si vous le
permettez par vous monsieur le le
président effectivement
plusieurs sénateurs et vous même relever
cette différence ce
ce ce ce gouffre qui est existe entre
les travaux universitaires et ce qui se
passe à l'école et une des choses qui
m'a énormément surpris lorsque j'ai
commencé à réfléchir au problème j'ai
rencontré quelques enfin un assez grand
nombre de grands noms parmi les
historiens français les chercheurs ceux
qui publient ceux qui sont connus
internationalement et et quand je leur
ai présenté les les premières
conclusions préconclusions de aus
travaux ils étaient totalement huris
parce je me suis rendu compte que même
les meilleurs spécialistes français de
pays d'autres pays
européens qui connaissent à fond
l'histoire des autres pays européens qui
sont en contact permanent avec leurs
homologues du monde entier notamment des
pays quis étudient ne s'intéresse
absolument pas à ce qui se passe dans
les salles de classe de ces
pays et donc quand je montre le panorama
global en disant bah vous savez on est
entre le nationalisme et la
affolement
euh alors il y a un autre phénomène mais
là sur cet autre phénomène je vais
donner une interprétation tout à fait
personnelle qui n'est pas du tout celle
d'un historien moi je suis un ENF
j'étais un politique j'ai besoin de
l'histoire pour faire de la
politique dans le bon sens du terme
c'est-à-dire pour conforter la
réconciliation entre nos peuples pour le
reste donc la préoccupation au fond
derrière l'Observatoire c'est la qualité
de l'enseignement de la pédagogie et
cetera mais c'est aussi s'assurer que
conformément aux recommandations
adoptées qui sont remarquablement
rédigées par le Conseil de l'Europe
parfois d'ailleurs par l'Union
européenne euh par l'UNESCO et cetera
euh l'histoire est enseignée à partir de
faits prouvés documentés
vérifiés deuxièmement euh que
euh l'histoire est est est enseigné dans
une perspective de la multiperspectivité
c'estd en écoutant le récit de l'autre
et avec la volonté de de réconcilier les
autres enfin les uns de réconcilier les
uns et les autres
et puisque c'est une compétence
nationale et ça le restera pendant
longtemps s'assurer que ces récits
nationaux
différents laisse
émerger une alors quel est le bon mot
une civilisation une culture une
communauté d'esprit
européenne c'est c'est c'est ça quelle
est le la préoccupation or or au niveau
universitaire au moins dans le cas de la
France l'impression que j'ai comme
consommateur d'histoire pas comme
historien c'est qu'en fait les il y a
deux écoles qui rivalisent et rivalisent
qualité ce qui est excellent mais qui du
coup appauvrissent les autres approches
il y
a je simplifie abominablement les
historiens vont me taper dessus mais il
y a
l'école
mondialiste Boucheron donc histoire
mondiale de la
France et puis il y a l'histoire Pierre
Nora nationaloocentré alors absolument
pas nationaliste on peut pas accuser
Pierre Nora d'être
mais qui pousse à s'intéresser à ce que
ont été les origines historiques
culturelles euh de la nation française
de la République française de l'État
français les monuments les grands
ouvrages les traités de paix et cetera y
compris la la régionalisation de et
entre les deux bah il y a pas
l'Europe et alors j'invite max euh à
faire comme moi alors évidemment il faut
attendre euh tous les mois de décembre
quand je fais le Père Noël je vais à la
plus grande librairie de de chez nous
qui est la
FN et j'aime mais mais mais vous pouvez
le faire pas loin d'ici à la librairie
des sciences politiques rue Saint-
guuillaume j'ai fait le même exercice
devant le directeur de Science Po il y a
un ou de mois je dite venez vous ne
croyez pas venez regardez ce qu'il y a
en vitrine pas un titre sur l'histoire
de l'europeeur pas un titre sur la
construction européenne dans les à la
flque de Bayonne tous les ans en
décembre euh rayon histoire je compte le
nombre de livres sur les principaux
sujets chaque année il y a un sujet à la
mode alors ça a été B quand il y a eu le
centenaire de euh enfin le
l'anniversaire de la paix en Algérie en
euh bon ça a été évidemment l'année
dernière l'Algérie l'histoire de
l'Algérie l'oire de la colonisation une
dizaine de titres l'année d'avant
c'était le centenaire ou le bicentenaire
de la mort de Napoléon 2021 donc
euh une douzaine de titres de Napoléon
tous les ans tous les ans plus de 50
titres nouveau sur la deuxè guerre
mondiale
50 titres sur la 2è guerre mondiale 80
ans après euh et là-dedans plus de la
moitié des titres sur la
choix 80 ans après bon tant mieux sur
l'Union européenne rien biographie d'un
grand Européen rien zéro pas un seul
titre et pourquoi il y a pas de titre ça
n'intéresse pas les éditeurs et il y a
pas de travaux de recherche là-dessus je
reviens sur sciencesp Paris qui qui est
quand même un des grands centres
d'enseignement de l'histoire
contemporaine et ben ce n'est que cette
année que l'histoire de la construction
européenne devient une matière redevient
une matière obligatoire à SP qu'elle
était quand j'ai fait sciencep ça REM à
quelques temps et donc il y a pas
d'intérêt aujourd'hui de la recherche en
France et là c'est la même chose
ailleurs sur l'histoire de l'Europe et
de la construction européenne je donne
un seul
exemple faisant écho à ce que disait
tout à l'heure monsieur monsieur ouas le
grand historien américain Timothy
sneider qui vient de faire paraître
enfin la version française de son
dernier ouvrage la route de l'esclavage
vient de paraître c'est un régal et même
temps choses inquiétant Timothy sneider
remarque que les Européens s'enfermant
dans des histoires vu d'un point de vue
national ne prennent pas conscience du
fait qu'il y a eu des phénomènes
européens avant même la construction
européne exemple les révolutions de
1848 c'est la première manifestation
d'une opinion publique européenne et
d'une aspiration européenne à la liberté
à l'égalité et aussi d'ailleurs à la
constitution de de nation mais quand on
regarde Emmanuel de chaclon de nos pays
ben la France ne parle que de la
révolution de
1848 les les autres pays font
rigoureusement de même chose plus
surprenante en tout cas qui moi m'a
surpris
timoth sneider encore une fois historien
américain considéré comme un des
meilleurs
aujourd'hui dit les Européens ne sont
pas conscients du fait que le plus
ancien des peuples européens qui survit
encore aujourd'hui alors c'est c'est pas
les Gaulois effectivement qui ont
disparu euh mais c'est le peuple
[Musique]
juif le peuple européen le plus ancien
qui est toujours là malgré les efforts
d'Hitler et et d'autres euh bah c'est le
peuple juif et comme il y a pas
d'histoire de l'Europe ben on nenseigne
pas l'histoire du peuple juif voilà donc
il y a ce problème que l'on rencontre
partout euh
de la manière de faire prendre en compte
par le euh l'enseignement secondaire et
primaire
et je je suis complètement d'accord avec
ce qui a été dit sur euh l'Ance
de
l'école primaire pour l'enseignement de
l'histoire en fait c'est en
CM2 c'est en CM2 qu'il faut apprendre
les bases de l'histoire et les personnes
et les
personnalité parce que ça on s'en
souvient sentimentalement toute sa vie
le reste on l'prend intellectuellement
mais alors là on tombe autant de pays
autant de situations il y a des pays
dans lesquels
notamment l'Allemagne et je ne sais pas
pourquoi l'Estonie où on n'apprend pas
l'histoire en
primaire ça ne commence qu'en
seconde et il y a au moins un
pays où on apprend l'histoire qu'en
primaire ce qui est pas idéal non plus
qui l'Irlande du Sud pour des raisons
liées à l'histoire de l'indépendance
l'Irlande ENF j'ai pas le temps de
d'élaborer làdessus mais voilà donc ça
il y a il y a il y a nettement la
nécessité de
euh de mieux veiller à ce qu'il a une
courroie transmission entre les les
apports de la recherche et y compris
paradox ça peut paraître paradoxal au
non initié sur les temps les plus
anciens il y a
euh des
progrès
régulier qui ne sont pas pris en compte
par le l'enseignement euh
alors comment s'assurer que cette
dimension
plurinationale notamment
européenne soit mieux prise en compte
j'ai longtemps cru qu'une bonne approche
serait de mettre des Européens de tous
les pays autour de la table pour qu'ils
se mettent d'accord sur un récit
commun j'avais même constitué un groupe
quand j'étais ministre des affaires
européennes un groupe gr d'étudiants de
d'universitaires prestigieux de tous les
pays de l'époque pour essayer de faire
un texte commun je me suis rendu compte
que c'est une erreur
absolue parce que si on élabore une
histoire de l'Europe par comité
d'historien mis à part les auteurs de
cette histoire tout le monde sera contre
les autres historiens seront furieux
bien entendu et puis les opinions
publiques ça ça va être ah ben oui
l'histoire sainte de l'Europe Saint-Jean
Monet ou Saint Robert Schuman qui
d'ailleurs va peut-être finir par être
béatifié mais euh non c'est pas ça du
tout ce qu'il faut et alors là on tombe
sur le problème relevé par plusieurs
d'entre vous le fait que Ben les
programmes d'histoire sont déjà
surchargé alors s'il faut élargir à
l'histoire des pays voisins là la
recommandation que je fais alors il y a
eu l'approche ça a été cité euh par l'un
de vous du manuel
franco-allemand le manuel
franco-allemand alors qui est une
histoire
commune histoire contemporaine des deux
derniers siècles
19e2e avec un texte identique des
illustrations identiques des
commentaires identiques à la langue prê
c'est c'est traduit mais rigoureusement
de la même
manière c'est très intéressant sauf que
un ça a été un très petit succès de
librairie
pourquoi parce que les professeurs sont
libres de choisir leur manuel
et les professeurs l'ont pas choisi sauf
dans les écoles qui les lycées qui
délivre laabbac à la fois laabitour et
et le baccalauréat français qui sont
écoles bilingues ou dans les écoles
européennes et puis deuxème raison ce
manuel il n'a jamais été mis à jour or
en
Allemagne l'éducation le contenu des
programmes le statut des manuels et
cetera sont de compétences des régions
des
lenders le
la Fédération le boun a l'interdiction
il y a le mot faireb dans la
constitution allemande dans la GRE
gosette de s'occuper de d'éducation et
bon alors en France les ministes
d'éducation ont tendance à changer assez
fréquemment et et il ch les programmes
et donc et puis les ler les programmes
sont pas les mêmes son les lenders donc
du
coup ce manuel a été choisi mais mais le
simple fait qu'il a existé et que
quelquesuns des meilleurs enseignants
français et allemands pendant 2 ans ce
soit mis en sort pour se mettre d'accord
sur la manière de raconter le passé
c'est un formidable exemple de
réconciliation des mémoires max évoquait
à juste titre la différence entre
l'histoire et la
mémoire qui est un point qui est un
point fondamental et donc plutôt que
d'essayer d'avoir une histoire commune
à tous les pays européens ou un certain
nombre de pays ma recommandation c'est à
travers la multierspectivité le
croisement des regards prendre quelques
exemples par
exemple le 11 novembre 1918 comment cela
a-t-il été vécu en France et dans les
principaux pays concernés je prends cet
exemple parce que c'est ça m'a surpris
le sujet qui a été le plus difficile à
traiter pour les auteurs de Manuel
franco allemand c'est très curieux
pourquoi parce qu'en France ben pour
nous on en garde souvenir de la victoire
mine de rien la dernière victoire de
l'armée française ça
remonte victoire acquise à un prix
humain considérable mais enfin grande
victoire en Allemagne au contraire c'est
le souvenir de ce qu'ils ont appelé le
coup de poignard dans le dos c'est
Allemagne est né à ce moment-là la
légende selon laquelle c'est le pouvoir
politique qui était en déliquissence à à
Berlin qui avait supplié les alliés de
la l'armistice alors que l'armée
allemande avait quand même encore 1
million de soldat sur le sol français et
qui avait pas encore une seule paire de
bottes français sur le sol allemand et
donc côté allemand il voit dans le 11
novembre et sa mauvaise interprétation
le début d'un processus abominable qui a
conduit après la Rép de weimmar
à
Hitler
sur alors plutôt que d'essayer se mettre
d'accord sur un récit commun il faut
écouter le récit de l'autre oui en
France voilà comment ça a été vécu en
Allemagne voilà quelles ont été les
conséquences et aller au-delà en Pologne
la Pologne dans un premier temps avait
fait du 11 novembre la fête nationale
parce que ben c'est à ce moment-là que
la Pologne a reconquis son indépendance
qu'elle avait perdu depuis plus d'un
siècle euh en Hongrie ça a débouché sur
la catastrophe du traité de Trianon
perte de 2 ti3 du territoire et de 2/3
de la population donc c'est un un jour
de deuil par contre en Roumanie pour la
raison inverse c'est aussi une fête
nationale c'est et on on on a et et en
Espagne ben il l'enseigne pas puisque
l'Espagne n'a pas participé à la
Première Guerre mondiale donc voilà donc
il faut comprendre ça et croiser les euh
regard alors madame Olivier
euh dit suggère que on doit à l'école
apprendre aux enfants à lire les réseaux
sociaux et et à àire enfin à faire la
part des choses alors là c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est l'approche
allemande de l'enseignement
d'histoire
euh et la différence d'origine depuis ça
s'est beaucoup rapproché entre
l'approche française et approche
allemande est la suivante en France on a
enseigné l'histoire pour enseigner des
connaissances donc voilà ce qui s'est
passé dans le
passé donc autant que possible
chronologiquement bon là-dessus il y a
eu des des haut et des bas mais enfinon
en Allemagne on enseignait
l'histoire pour enseigner des
compétences parce que comme l'Allemagne
après 1945 l'Allemagne de l'Ouest avait
honte de son passé de son passé du 19e
aussi du passé du du mais aussi du 19e
parce que bon enfin quand même passé
très nationaliste et quand on remonte à
la Prusse de Frédéric II c'était pas
idéal non plus donc ils ont voulu former
des citoyens qui soient capables de
résister à la propagande officielle et
donc ils apprennent un peu la formation
des historiens ils forment des petits
historiens vérifier l'origine des
sources les croiser les
compléter interpréter les
documents voilà et et donc c'est ça
qu'il faut faire alors ce qu'il faut
maintenant idéalement c'est l'appliquer
effectivement à ces sources
d'information extraordinairement
nombreuses et et trop souvent empoisonné
que sont les réseaux sociaux c'est le le
conseil que je donne le nombre des
membres
euh donc et jusqu'à présent été limité à
17 alors nous avons été victimes au
départ pour un avoir davantage de la
pandémie des conséquences de la pandémie
et puis s'est produit aussi un un
problème c'est nous étions en
2019-220 donc avant la guerre de 2022
mais après
2014 l'annexion de la Crimée par la
Russie et donc il s'est produit un
phénomène assez curieux très intéressant
c'est que la présence de la Russie qui a
voulu être parmi les pays
fondateurs et naturellement qu'on n pas
exclu à priori alors on les a exclus
depuis
2022 à dissuader les pays voisins de la
Russie de joindre l'Observatoire parce
qu'ils se sont dit s'il y a les Russes
c'est biaisé d'emblé par contre la
présence de la Turquie qui a voulu faire
partie des pays fondateurs a encouragé
les pays voisins à faire partie de
l'Observatoire et ça c'est très
intéressant et ça rend optimiste pour
l'avenir parce
que sont venus me voir l'un après
l'autre et sans être
concerté le représentant Turquie puis le
représentant de
l'Arménie et quand ceci se produit dis
c'était dans la période dans une des
périodes chaudes entre l'Azerbaïjan
soutenu par la Turquie et
l'Arménie en me disant bon bah comme il
faudra quand même un jour qu'on
réconcilie nos
mémoires si on veut aboutir des
relations diplomatiques normales entre
nos pays bah ça serait pas mal qu'on
travaille ensemble voilà et ça c'est
tout à fait intéressant alors depuis la
guerre de d'Ukraine évidemment le
sentiment vis-àvis de la Russie a
complètement changé donc du coup
l'Ukraine est devenu membre de l'Union
européenne de l'Union européenne de
l'Observatoire la Moldavie a fait le
premier pas avec le statut d'observateur
je vais m'y rendre prochainement pour
entériner l'entrée de la Moldavie et je
vais me rendre en Pologne maintenant que
le changement de gouvernement en Pologne
va rendre les contacts plus facile voilà
et donc j'ai j'ai bon espoir que nous
allons
pouvoir compléter notre échantillon en
Allemagne nous nous heurtons à un
problème depuis l'origine que je n'ai
pas pu surmonter
euh qui est qui est la compétence des
lender mais avec aussi l'obligation
d'avoir l'accord de Berlin parce que les
lendurs sont entièrement compétents sur
le contenu des programmes mais ils n'ont
pas le droit de signer des des accords
internationaux mon petit organe c'est
quand même un organe international donc
l'adhésion sera juridiquement un traité
qui ne pourra être signé qu'à Berlin
voilà donc il faut qu'il se metent
d'accord alors quand je rencontre les
lender ils me disent bah si ça ne Ten
est qu'à nous oui mais c'est Berlin qui
veut pas et quand je rencontre Berlin
ils me font la réponse contraire bon ce
que je souhaite c'est qu'à l'occasion
d'un sommet franco-allemand euh on en
parle au plus haut niveau parce que
depuis la guerre d'Ukraine et et les
motifs qui on été donnés comme cela a
été rappelé par le président président
Poutine enfin le fait évidemment c'est
une action à long terme mais enfin le
fait de mettre en place un système qui
consolidera la réconciliation entre nos
peup plutôt que d'encourager des pays à
faire comme la Russie a raconter
n'importe quoi sur le passé ça devient
d'une
importance considérable même pour nos
dirigeants même dans les pays où le
contenu des programmes est décidé au
niveau au niveau régional
euh voilà
alors alors la question posée par
Monsieur
chanrel sur
la la labélisation des manuels alors sur
le statut manuel il y a tous les
systèmes donc en
France et dans très peu de pays il y a
liberté totale n'importe qui d'entre
nous peut écrire un manuel et s trouve
un éditeur et n'importe quel professeur
peut le
choisir à l'autre bout il y a des pays
avec un seul manuel oblig par niveau de
classe y compris des pays qui sont des
démocraties qui marchent pas mal mais où
bon je vous laisse juge et puis il y a
toutes les gammes
intermédiaires la solution la plus
fréquemment retenue c'est la
labellisation simplement alors c'est le
cas en
Allemagne simplement pour s'assurer que
le manuel traite bien le programme du
cours de l'année c'est tout sans entré
sur la manière dont il le traite ça ne
pose aucun problème dans ces pays
personne ne l'a jamais
contesté
donc je prends pas parti
sur les projets éventuels simplement je
constate que sans labellisation ça
marche très bien en France et là c'est
l'ancien homme politique qui parle
changer un truc qui marche on a déjà
suffisamment de mal à changer ce qui
marche
pas enfin voilà bon je
bon
euh alors je voudrais peut-être achever
attendez je j'ai pas tout traité je m'en
excuse euh mais si vous avez d'autres
questions je pourrais répondre par écrit
mais je voudrais achever par des en
revenant d'ailleurs à des propositions à
d'entre
vous sur des recommandations qu'à titre
personnel je pense qu'il serait utile de
faire au niveau de l'Union européenne
pour les membres de l'Union européenne
hein Conseil de l'Europe bon mais les
membres de l'Union
européenne d'abord je pense que alors
oui je pense l'Union européenne d'autant
que en ce moment même votre homologue
avec qui vous devit être en contact du
Parlement européen travaille sur le
sujet avec l'idée de faire des
recommandations et donc il m'ont
auditionné j'ai donné un certain nombre
de
suggestions ça moi je trouve que ça bien
si tous les pays de l'Union européenne
s'engageaient à enseigner l'histoire or
certains d'entre eux ne l'enseignent
plus et l'histoire ça veut dire
chronologique hein c'est pas simplement
un flash sur un
événement ou sur une réforme ou sur une
révolution un moment donné comprendre
l'enchaînement des
événements
deuxièmement que tout s'engage enseigne
l'histoire de la construction européenne
la moitié des 27 pays la moitié je sais
pas euh de c'était la moitié quand on
était 28 donc ça veut dire 14 euh des 27
pays euh non ou 13 parce que là-dedans
il y avait il y avait le royaummeeuni
enfin peu importe en gros la moitié euh
des pays membres de l'Union européenne
au titre d'histoire contemporaine
n'enseigne pas l'histoire de la
construction européenne euh j'enseigne
le budget européen à sciencep dans ma
classe j'ai en ce
moment des euh des Allemands des
Italiens des Espagnols des Suédois des
Finlandais notamment puis des des noms
des nom Union européenne Suisse et
chinois la semaine dernière j'ai parlé
de jeanmis ils ont écarquillé les
yeux j'ai parlé de Conrad adnauer les
Allemands étaient content les Français
n'avaient jamais entendu parler
conradauer
donc s'obliger à enseigner l'histoire de
la construction
européenne je propose
aussi un erasmous pour les professeurs
d'histoire si on veut que chaque
professeur vive la
multiperspectivité pour avoir
l'équivalent du CAPS obligé à faire
l'équivalent d'un stage enfin pendant
plusieurs mois dans un pays voisin pour
enseigner selon d'ailleurs le le le
programme et l'émanuel du pays voisin et
puis revenir chez soi je crois que la
multiperspectivité serait pas mal il y a
beaucoup d'argent à erasmous et on sait
pas trop quoi en
faire autre chose plus importante alors
là on est au cœur de la de la politique
euh puisque l'Union européenne va
s'ouvrir à de nouveaux pays de nouveaux
membres introduire dans les critères
d'adhésion ajoutter aux trois critères
d'adhésion
un
4è qui est ne peuvent entrer dans
l'Union européenne que des pays
réconciliés avec leurs voisins c'est la
moindre des choses parce que nous avons
réussi le miracle de la paix de
réconciliation entre nous nous n'allons
pas faire entrer dans une famille
réconcilié quelqu'un qui va tout de
suite expliquer qu'il est fâché soit
avec l'un de nous soit avec un
paystiers bon il y a le problème Ukraine
russieir mais sinon dans les pays
candidats par exemple la Serbie et le
Kosovo vont pas entrer euh tant qu'ils
sont à couteau tirés c'est pas possible
hein euh voilà la Macédoine du Nord doit
réconcilier son histoire avec la
Bulgarie et d'ailleurs nous sommes prêts
à y travailler j'ai fait un som
suggestion au sein de l'Observatoire
pour les aider à le faire non pas pour
me mettre à leur place mais pour les
aider à être autour de la table et à et
à échanger entre eux un critère
d'accession ça me paraît extrêmement
important temps j'ai j'ai soumis cette
idée aux autres autorités de la
République et alors il m'est venu une
idée mais l'un de vous je ne sais pas si
c'est Monsieur chanterel ou monsieur
ousouias oui monsieur ousouias avec le
droit de la liberté
académique moi j'avais une formule al
c'est explosif
hein enfin au
Sénat on sait euh
euh éteindre les les explosivs enfin les
rendre comestibles si je puis dire
bon mettre quelque part dans un bout de
loi pas dans la Constitution compliquons
pas trop tout citoyen français a le
droit et le devoir de connaître
l'histoire de
France alors chaque mot euh
suscite des objections des
problèmes mais ça veut dire que bah il
faut enseigner
l'histoire et ça veut dire
que pour être un citoyen français qui
n'est pas originaire de France c'est pas
mal de connaître
l'histoire sachant que je termine par là
certains des pays qui n'enseignent plus
l'histoire se trouve aujourd'hui dans
une situation assez
cocasse dans lequel devant une pression
migratoire forte venu de pays non
européens avec au bout de quelques
années des demandes de
naturalisation ils ont adopté des lois
selon lequel pour être citoyen de leur
pays il fallait connaître l'histoire du
pays donc le paradoxe c'est que dans ces
pays les nations non nées dans le pays
ne connaissent pas l'histoire
mais les citoyens de souche plus récent
sont obligés de la connaître du coup ils
vont être conduits à généraliser
l'enseignement de
l'histoire alors là on manie de la
dynamite hein mais mais en même temps si
l'enjeu sur le long terme c'est bien la
réconciliation ou le retour à un état de
guerre ou à des rivalités permanentes il
y a un moment où il faudra prendre des
risques mercici président pardon merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président c'était
passionnant et on ne parle pas assez
d'histoire donc l'avoir fait à travers
vos travaux et et ceux de l'Observatoire
c'était pour nous très enrichissant
merci beaucoup je vais inviter les
rapporteurs de la PPL à à me rejoindre
je vais raccompagner Alain lamassour si
vous me le permettez mais vous pouvez
commencer le
rapport